月个月图一图，
你别又图着说他在北京全款有房，
又图着他全家就可尊重我了，
他把我当个人了，
不会的，
就是我是26岁，
是本科，
目前在北京的一家国企工作，
月薪的话是7~9K这样，
是家里的独生女，
父母都是农村的，
家里是有一个自建房，
母有一些积蓄养老，
就是自己上的那个灵活就业，
到了年龄之后每个人有1000左右的工资，
然后男朋友的话是比我大四岁，
我们之前是有了两年的那个异地，
最近一年是在一起跟我，
然后他的话是在北京工作，
是能家居的行业，
之前的话是月入大概1.5这样，
年初的时候遇到的公司裁员的工作，
就是在做的是销售，
月入是7K左右，
他父母的话也是农村的，
他也是独生子，
他父母的话是在老家摆摊做小生意，
以前的话收入200左右吧，
他家县城有一个房子，
好像还有一点房贷没还完，
有一个代步车，
就目前他们手头没有什么积蓄，
我们两家的话离得有1000多公里，
我跟我妈还有男朋友，
就是都在北京工作，
是合作在一起，
本来是定在20号要订婚，
我对象的话是手头有50万左右的积蓄，
打算是18万八给彩礼，
然后30万的话作为买房的首付，
他爸妈的话是。
呃，
给了我3万的三金钱，
他买房的话，
他们就说会帮，
但是也没有说具体给多少，
后来我跟我男朋友沟通了之后，
说是打算出10万，
就是最一开始沟通的时候，
然后最近沟通的话，
就是因为这个事儿，
我自己心里一直不踏实嘛，
就觉得没有父母帮衬，
然后我俩的话生活就是能力也有限啊，
就是沟通说还能在买房的时候给10万。
男朋友的性格的话就是平时比较平和，
不暴躁，
但是我们一起相处的话也有一些小问题，
就是最近一年因为之前都是异地，
就是没有太了解，
今年了解了之后就觉得，
嗯，
我俩都比较懒，
就家务上也吵过几回，
后来算式沟通了，
然后解决了。
他的话从小就是父母在外打工，
他是留守儿童，
有时候不表达自己的想法，
就跟我的，
有时候也不太表达这种情感，
然后我也是这种，
就是我父亲是NP地，
母亲的话就是比较宠我，
我的话也有点脾气不太好，
他会表达自己的感情，
但是就是我觉得他比我大一些，
他有时候呢，
容忍我的脾气，
容忍我的性格，
会跟我说怎么来解决这个事情，
就是想让我们越来越好，
但是就是觉得你跟他在经济上有点过不去，
就想让您帮我提一建议，
其实啊，
就是这个男生本身人家真的挺优秀的，
人家能存50万的存款，
也没有什么不良的嗜好，
也没有任何的这个外债，
这个男生本身真的是。
挺优秀的，
咱们任何角色都要看看我自己手上的牌是什么，
就客观的讲，
你是属于那种长相特别招人喜欢的，
性格特别招人喜欢的，
追你的人特别多的那种女孩子吗？
我自己身你概觉也不是，
然后你父亲还是一个NPD人格，
类似于NPD人格，
你和妈妈相依为命，
那将来的话就得双方的家庭都帮衬帮衬，
比如说你的妈妈帮你带孩子，
我觉得就是我妈的话，
可能也会帮我带孩子，
就是我之前也觉得说是他能包容我的脾气，
就是虽然有些小问题，
就是我有一些结婚的朋友吧，
他们就给我建议说是双方父母都帮衬一下，
这个日子才好往后过，
要不然的话，
以后会因为经济上的问题就是经常吵架，
这样我就是在犹豫这个事儿，
还是那句话，
姑娘，
我们在要求别人的时候，
先看一下我手上有什么牌，
你要今天告诉我说王菲姐，
我这个虽然说我家境不太好，
但是我学习成绩好，
我性格好，
我长得也不赖，
所以追我的人挺多的，
如果是这种情况的话，
咱可以挑一挑，
如果不是这种情况的话，
从咱自身的条件来看的话，
也没有什么太大的优势，
不管是说学历呀，
性格呀，
长相啊，
招人喜欢的程度，
如果没有什么太大的优势的话，
那我就看看这个男生，
他对自己负责任吗？
他本身他自己身体健康吗？
他努力工作吗？
他钱有规划吗？
他对自己的人生有责任心吗？
他如果说自己就能存下来50万的存款的话，
你就。
他在男生当中已经是佼佼者了，
真的我真的没有骗你们啊，
就有的时候我们要降低期待，
我们要降低期待，
真的就现在像能存下来50万存款的男同学真的不多，
像他这个年纪30岁，
有50万的存款，
没有任何负债，
我感觉凤毛麟角，
而且我觉得我俩性格的话都是有点不太会表达，
然后有点情感在摩，
就他可能会比我好一俩，
更能那个理解人一些，
就可能我确实也有这方面问题，
我也在自己想改进，
我就感觉我不知道在图他些什么，
我觉得人家自己的生活，
人家安排的明明白白的呀，
人家不会给你拖后腿呀，
而且人家挺尊重你的呀，
人家上来之后给十八万八的彩礼呀，
我给你讲的就这几点的话，
已经超过了多少人啊，
你真的去婚恋市场看看吧，
看看现在婚恋市场这些男生的，
看看他们的态度，
看看他们的观点，
看看他们的诉求吧，
他自己的生活他安排的明明白白的，
他对女性有一份尊重，
在他给你有一个交代，
在他愿意给十八万八的彩礼完了之后，
他没有任何的负债，
没有什么不良的嗜好的话，
就已经很难得了。
嗯，
是吗？
那可能我想的太的理想，
我也想过，
就是如果我不跟他在一起的话，
我能遇到什么样的人，
这样就比如说买房子方面，
我可能压力小一点儿，
可能有父母会给买一个房子，
就是男方父母或者付一个首付，
就是不用自己，
就是两个人在负担这个房子的事儿，
可能在处理两个人的情况。
那时候就会没那么大压力，
其实你们可能未必，
因为你们俩的工作都不是国企，
都是给人打工的，
所以你俩未必要定居在一线城市，
你俩就是在一线城市挣点钱，
将来就是找一个房价低的城市去定居，
这是比较理性的做法。
我是在国企，
我觉得我的能力可能也没那么强，
你就是说你不可能跟着他换工作，
你在北京就肯定是在北京生存了，
是这意思哈，
我目前是这样想的，
就是因为我感觉我也没有能力说比其他城市，
然后找一个适合我的工作，
那你找对象的时候，
你目标就应该明确一点，
你找对象的时候就应该找在北京有房的，
你就不该跟他谈四年的恋爱，
确实我的目标有会明确，
对呀，
你的背后也是没有什么帮衬的嘛，
爸妈根本上就是帮不上任何的忙，
你唯一有一张牌，
就是说你在北京有一个稳定的工作，
可能你年轻，
有生育价值，
你唯一有的牌就这些，
你当初找的时候，
你就应该目标明确，
你就找那个有房子的，
不用还房贷的，
但是我会跟你讲的，
姑娘啊，
你想把日子过好的话，
你就得有牺牲，
因为一旦你找了那个有房子的，
没有房贷的，
人家难道不知道你图啥吗？
那你去的时候，
你觉得人家会全家人都很尊重你吗？
人家不得把你当保姆使唤呀，
或者做饭都是你，
打扫卫生都是你啊，
伺候公婆都是你啊，
我琢磨呀，
就是这个逻辑，
但凡在北京有全款有房的，
我说的是不是这个道理，
你在北京全款有房，
你找个外地的媳妇儿，
你图啥你是不？
她来家里免费当保姆，
那你还想说他在北京全款有房，
我去了之后，
他家还能特别尊重我，
还能怎么怎么地的，
还能上来就给我十八万八的彩礼，
那未必啊，
因为人家在北京能全款买得起房子，
要么是北京土著，
要么就是属于那种真的啊，
就家里面有家底儿的，
我跟你说，
你得图一投，
你别又图着说他在北京全款有房，
又图着他全家就可尊重我了，
可把我当个人了，
不会的，
自己想好了啊，
想好了就是按照自己想要的这个方向去找，
但是一定是也牺牲，
嗯，
你说牺牲哪个好一点？
其实我的性格来说的话啊，
实话实说，
因为人和人性格不一样，
我的性格我真的不能跟那种不尊重的我在一起生活，
我的性格是这样，
因为我从小就自卑嘛，
家里越穷，
越穷的人越需要得到别人的尊重，
你知道吧，
我宁可是面对公公婆婆的时候，
我给钱，
我给你们钱，
我都不会图公公婆婆说给我什么钱，
完了之后我还得哈着公公婆婆礼数上还得到位，
逢年过节了还得那个什么敬茶什么的，
我不，
我宁可选择就是说公公婆婆想我给我给我就是这种性格，
我就是充分的这个分析自己的性格，
看自己的性格适合什么样的，
可能是我还没有太认清自己，
然后不知道你想要什么，
我们比的不是说跟别人比啊，
比的是谁先找到自己，
先成为自己，
先活成自己，
你要认真的去分析一下你自己啊，
那你对我就是其他的还有什么建议。
好好做工作，
就是在你这个国企工作的基础之上的话，
你还是得居安思危呢，
就琢磨一下能考个什么证啊，
琢磨一下能干点什么，
只要不违法，
只要不犯罪，
只要说不是太那个啥的话，
能多挣点钱，
嗯，
好那的就这样啊，
再见，
嗯，
拜拜。
刚刚有人说北京有房的人真的是只想找一个保姆吗？
我那个说法呢，
当然是一个夸张的说法，
就是因为大家现在都很现实，
如果人家在北京市全款有房，
人家再找一个对象的时候，
人家不挑吗？
人家也得挑是不是？
人家得挑你来到我的家里来，
你能给我家里干啥是不是？
你还指望说人家北京全款有房的人，
人家把你娶过门了之后，
把你当祖宗一样供着，
把你当那个什么千金大小姐一样供着，
那不可能啊，
是不是这意思啊？
记得点赞关注哦。